so how do you measure the coastline of a
country let's draw a little bit of
coastline here make it nice and so
imagine this is somewhere in the north
of Scotland or something like that we
see this is the sea here okay all right
is a really big ruler and just kind of
line it up and go around and see how
much we've got so I'm going to use a
ruler that's about this long there's one
lot of ruler there there's two a three
four five six seven eight nine so this
coastline is nine units along nine of
those rulers and long but I'm not
getting into all the nooks and crannies
and the lumps and bumps and stuff right
there so let's use a smaller ruler let's
use a ruler that is it is half the size
so I'm just going to do that just by eye
trying to work out the M so one at two
three four five six seven eight nine 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 I
did it by eye but I was trying to make
the the brown rulers half the size of
the orange rulers so 2 9 0 18 we've
ended up with 4 extra short rulers so by
measuring with the shorter ruler we've
got a longer length of coastline this is
always the case so the smaller I make
the ruler the the bigger the answer I'm
getting into more of the little nooks
and crannies that's the important thing
so the more kind of lumps and bumps you
get into the the bigger the answer you
get so the question then becomes how how
small does that really need to be so
let's have a look at a few examples of
of different scales let's zoom in on a
little bit of this coastline here so as
if we're flying along in a plane and so
this bit of coastline might look like
that
as we zoom in let's zoom in even further
so we're looking a craggy sort of rock
edge what might that look like
and that craggy rock edge might look
something like that so we want to zoom
in even further maybe a little rock
that's jutting out from from that edge
so it
we're crouching down we're eyeballing a
bit of rock and maybe that bit of rock
looks something like that
we get our
microscope out and we have a look even
closer at the sort of fine grained
detail of the rock and maybe it looks
something like that the problem is it's
lumpy and bumpy all the way down there's
no obvious point where we say okay this
is the size of our ruler so we need a
ruler that kind of got into all the sort
of molecular lumps and bumps to get a
true answer but is that true answer it
would be a meaningless answer it would
be it would be you know hundreds
thousands millions of times greater than
than what we've got at this scale
depending on how low you go down
suddenly we're measuring the coastline
of Britain say to be millions of
kilometers and that doesn't feel like a
useful answer so we present it to some
mathematicians to see what they think
and so let's have a look then at a sort
of mathematically perfect coastline
isn't that beautiful
Brady alert I know you'd like to know
where the sea is so here's the sea but
our mathematical coastline needs to
mirror the real-world coastline so it
needs to be lumpy and bumpy so let's put
a little lump in like that so now we've
got a lumpy bumpy coastline but we need
to be able to zoom in and for it to
continue to be lumping in the same way
that the real coastline is so now each
of these straight lines let's put a
little bump in all of these as well but
again we need to put a zoom in and for
it to still be lumpy bumpy's so now
every straight line that we've just
created needs to have a lumpy bit in it
as well this is the last one I'll draw
okay so to be like the coastline Britain
we need to keep doing this keep adding
lumps and bumps all the way down forever
or at least you know to some to some
high degree so how do we measure the
coastline of this mathematical drawing
or how do we measure the length of this
okay so we can notice that this small
section here is the same as the whole
thing but shrunk down so if we take that
whole thing and shrink it down that's
that's what you get
section here is a third of the whole
thing so the whole another in other
words the whole thing is three times
bigger than this one section but let's
look at it another way this bit here is
the same as this bit and this bit and
this bit so we've actually got one two
three four so this the whole thing is
three times bigger than that section and
it's four times bigger so how can it be
that the whole thing is three times
bigger and four times bigger is there a
number that you can multiply by three
and four and get the same answer
well there's zero so 0 times 3 is 0 0
times 4 is 0 so the coastline is zero
meters long that doesn't work because we
can see it the other option is it's not
really number but it's it's infinity
it's infinite so you know 3 times
infinity is infinite 4 times infinity is
infinite so the conclusion is that in
this mathematical case at least so long
as those lumps and bumps carry on
forever it's infinitely long and that's
in a sense true for the coastline of
Britain coastline Britain isn't
infinitely long because you get down to
the molecular level but to all intents
and purposes it has no length it's not
something we can we can give a number to
it in any meaningful way the guy that
did this well this is called a Koch
snowflake but the guy that came up with
all the stuff is Benoit be Mandelbrot
the B stands for Benoit be Mandelbrot by
the way and there he invented this thing
called fractal maths and so although we
it's kind of we're left in this position
where okay we can't measure the
coastline of Britain we now have some
mathematical tools for describing it so
we can talk about the lumpiness of
britain so all the fractal nosov britain
and it's a figure it is now it's like no
point to lumpy or whatever there's
somewhere there's some way now we have
of describing the fractal nature of our
own coastline and any coastline so yeah
that is how trying to
the coastline of a country leads to some
some really interesting mathematics you
didn't tell me how we can do it though
or the answer is we can't do the answer
is you can't do it sorry about that
I mean okay well look it up I mean the
thing is if you look it up you will find
either several different answers or
you'll find someone saying okay you know
we're going to agree that we use a ruler
that's an meter long or something like
that right and then you pick your
resolution your baby resolution you get
a number but it's kind of meaningless
because you're bigger different
resolution you get different number you
know you must be really fun to work with
I mean the other thing about the other
thing if you're measuring just at the
length of each for example you could you
could arguably measure the straight line
distance between one end of each and the
other you're not really getting the full
length of the beach but you're getting
some measure that's at least useful in
the same way you know you could say okay
I'm going to say the coastline of
Britain is the distance from Land's End
to John O'Groats double because it's far
too low the actual coastline is much
longer than that you know or is it is
that there's no answer